if there's someone I dislike the most
currently breathing in the universe in
Samuel Leeds
you're either not that confident or you
just haven't got the money well I'm
seeing it as a knockout and I think it
will be probably around one not gonna
have the gas in the tank to get past
around I've signed my contract he's not
signed his yet I'm gonna be bent
overholding over the corner is your wife
coming towards the fight I look forward
to seeing them well you're not going to
get past around one you'll be on the
floor of all bloody I think you're going
to be sorry you agreed to fight
good
okay so we're here today at the
Brentwood center where in four or five
weeks time Rob Moore and Samuel Leeds
will meet again for the final time where
they will clash in a very special
charity boxing match that has been
building up for months now since January
February time I think we started
building this flight ticket sales
absolutely flying out the door today we
also just come from an incredible
swearing session from both of your teams
actually that are looking to fight on
the undercard I must say whether they've
been training with you or not very high
standard for a white collar boxing fight
I haven't seen either one of you two
fights so I can't actually call yours I
could probably call some of theirs how
you've been training I've been training
hard yeah I've been training every day
fitness is up I've lost a lot of weight
I was like about 108 kilos when we last
met now I'm down to like 102 feeling
very confident I have seen some of your
photos I haven't seen no photos from
himself Rob no I don't need to show
anything don't need to use Photoshop
this is just me predictions changed for
the fight well I'm seeing it as a
knockout and I think it will be probably
M1 I think it's going to be a very well
you're not going to get past round one
so it's going to have to be your plan
you're not going to have the gas in the
tank to get past around one yeah it's
gonna be very very those big knockout
shots he's going to try and throw I'm
going to Tire him out and it's got to
reach me
it's a land one
got your back brace on
um no I I'm very confident it's going to
be a knockout I mean I'm a lot bigger a
lot stronger I've been training really
hard and I think it's going to be quite
an easy knockout I mean compared to a
lot of fights actually you two are kind
of walking into a little bit of Alliance
then in terms of with most fighting
you'll see some form of footage of
someone fighting previously I've seen
his white collar
seen that yeah you saw a bit of footage
of me five years ago doing a bit of
boxing I'm a lot better than that now
I've trained hard for this fight I'm a
lot fitter now a lot more on the line as
well 100 Grand yeah a lot of money going
to charity yeah are you going to donate
it to charity now yeah yeah well it was
50 last time wasn't it yeah because 50
was going to be Billboards yeah yeah
yeah I mean tongue-in-cheek joke
probably everything in fact I mean just
interestingly because I keep hearing Rob
saying 130 grounds going to charity
which is really strange because I put
100 Grand in the pot with my solicitors
so I'm putting 100 Grand Theft is 200
Grand 100 Grand in each yeah and when I
win and get that full 200 Grand the
whole of it's going to charity I'm gonna
be giving the 100 Grand I put in and 100
Grand that you put in 100 if it's going
to charity well I have a charity I have
a foundation I give hundreds of
thousands every year away so yeah all
the money in the purse all the money in
the purse will go to charity 200 Grand
yeah plus the proceeds of the event so
you can put in the 200 Grand in and the
breakfast the proceeds of the event oh
that's good I'm glad love to hear that
the full 200 is going to charity
half of the money for a car or something
yeah well that's just my little reward
for beating you oh yeah that's already
done how confident are you feeling then
you don't look Corner yeah I already won
the minute this was announced I saw in
the video you said that if you put a
percentage on it you'd say 99.9
reoccurring that you got this in the bag
yeah interesting yeah what makes you so
confident faster more accurate more
technical
yeah are you so confident I'm confident
because I'm just bigger and stronger and
I'm a good fighter and I've been
training really hard I've been training
you mean from the primary school fights
you've had near the ice cream van I'm
just very confident and looking at you
with respect I can tell that you're not
going to be very good you can't
I don't need to bully anyone I don't
need lawyers
this is my life oh interested
yeah except talking of lawyers full
draft contracts have been received all
signed or received everything back I've
signed my contract he's not signed his
yet Easter all is done say what you want
about him I don't think he'll pull out
he knows I won't pull out this is
happening 12 ounce gloves but if you
both decided on no haircuts three two
minute rounds that's all he was gonna do
you're not going past round one can it
be bent overholding over the corner
collapsing over the ropes after round
one right I don't know what you're
basing that on I agree I probably won't
get past round one because I won't need
to because the referral stopped it
you'll be on the floor for all bloody
that's what's gonna happen it's going to
be a knockout okay so one thing we do
need to decide the shoe ring walks first
and who ring walks second so we're going
to do a coin toss for it I've reviewed
mine which one calls which one doesn't
no I don't mind do you want to call your
lawyer and ask
I don't mind heads so you do mind
okay we're going heads you're happy
we're heads yeah yeah you can take heads
okay if you get heads you get towels you
choose if you ring walk first or second
we are heads heads I'm saying second
okay it's your ring walk first all of
your team will ring first your ring
second is your wife coming towards the
fight yeah what did you say on video you
were saying it's not just been hard for
me all the train it's been really hard
on my wife I don't remember saying that
the wife has it as hard as the fighter
for sure you've made up a lot of things
on this journey so you didn't say it's
been hard on your wife you didn't say
it's been really hard on my wife has it
been hard on your wife no comment about
my wife okay interesting I look forward
to seeing you on the night that wink
that's gonna be black
even if like you've got 10 free shots I
mean I wasn't allowed to move and you
punched me 10 times I don't think my
face will be bruised that might be a
good strategy actually just let him do
what he wants for 30 seconds put my
hands down and then bang him out I think
you're gonna be sorry you agreed to the
fight I feel a little bit sorry for you
because you don't seem like a terrible
person I feel like I feel a bit bad for
you
training companies bigger I'm way richer
you're gonna get owned your wife's gonna
be there watching It's just sad man it's
such a shame for you bro
after the fight would there be respect
between you two if he can get through
the full three rounds without even get
through the first round you know they'll
be respect if he gets through the full
three rounds yeah because I don't think
he will I don't think he'll get past one
round but if he just gets knocked out in
one round then it's just like delusional
as I thought yeah well generally boxing
is very respectful sport so hopefully
when this is all said and done
regardless of whether you're friends or
not there will be some level of respect
you get through three rounds yeah which
you can't based on oh well just look at
you no it's just obvious what do you
look at yeah okay anything to say to
each other
oh good luck I hope you're training
really really hard I'd be getting some
power training some explosive training
because I do worry for you I mean he's
had to even put in the contract he says
if you end up going to hospital and you
know like there's no liability on me I
had to make that really clear because I
do worry for him
nothing left to say this is my lawyer
sue this [__] well the next time
you will see each other will be fight
week and then after that the next time
you'll see each other will be when I'm
looking down like that standing over him
in the ring yeah
do we get handshakes
Good Luck Good Luck gentlemen all the
best for the fight it's been a pleasure
working with you both and I look forward
to the first of July here at the
Brentwood center can't come fast enough
man and I'm looking forward to not only
knocking you out but watching my whole
team not your team out that will be fun
too
especially this one right here
gentlemen it's great to see you great to
see you
see you soon